[This film will not be shown to the general
public without permission of the War Department.]
[War Department official training film. T.F.
8 2093 Army Service Forces]
[Produced by Army Pictorial Service Signal
Corps]
[Strictly Personal]
I'll bet she passed her physical with honors.
The Venus of Cyrene, approximately 400 B.C.
If the Greeks had a word for her, it certainly
would mean, "in perfect physical shape."
In perfect physical shape; yes that's what
it takes to do the man-sized job you've picked
for yourselves when you volunteered.
And that means more than just passing your
enlistment physical.
It means far more than gaining immunity from
contagious diseases through inoculations and
yearly booster shots.
Yes, and far more than getting a clean bill
of health at those monthly checkups.
Those things you can take for granted as part
of Army Medical Corps vigilance to protect
your health,
for your sickness might well undermine the
health of the entire group.
"Open up."
Report to sick call whenever you feel below
par, but be reasonable. Don't go running to
your medical officer for imaginary ailments.
There's a world of difference between indulging
yourself, and being good to yourself.
A world of difference between not being sick,
and feeling glowingly healthy.
Especially when you're doing a job in the
Army.
It's all the difference between dragging along
in a negative half-hearted way because your
vitality is low,
and living and working dynamically in a state
of positive well-being because you have a
reserve of energy to fall back on.
To help you achieve this, we are calling upon
a woman who has devoted her life to teaching
women the principles and technique of body
harmony
which increases one's effectiveness and attractiveness
in every department of living: Miss Helen
Matthews.
"This is the ideal average figure of the modern
American woman. And note I said average.
Did I hear someone say figures like that don't
exist outside Hollywood and the art galleries?
But they do.
The physical proportions of this lovely body
[unintelligible] Neck, bust, waist, hip, arm,
leg measurements are [unintelligible] average
American women ages 16 to 40.
And you'll be even more astonished when I
tell you they correspond closely to hers.
Now I'm not saying that each of you can make
yourself over in 10 easy lessons to look like
the Venus of Cyrene, but I am saying that
you modern women have an advantage over this
classic beauty--you have a head.
If you use it and your muscles and a little
self-discipline you'll be surprised how much
you personally can do to make yourself look
better and work better and longer with less
fatigue because you feel better.
There's no mystery to it. Feeling better simmers
down to following a few simple rules:
[Nutrition] It means paying more attention
to nutrition.
[Exercise] It means understanding and putting
heart into planned exercise.
[Rest] It means getting sufficient and proper
rest. Primarily rest means sleep, sound sleep,
health sleep, beauty sleep, which get your
body and mind a chance to recover from today's
activities in order to prepare for tomorrow's.
"Did I forget to lock the files? Why hasn't
Jim written? The Colonel's going to want the
paper tomorrow. It won't be finished. Why
can't I go to sleep?"
"You are all tied up in knots. Don't fight
so hard. Let go. Start with your arms and
legs. Let your whole body to limp gradually."
You can't expect to sleep until you relax.
Watch this silly little kitten.
She could give us all some valuable pointers
on the technique of relaxation. She knows
how to relax naturally. But we may have to
work for it.
Relaxing completely like this will help you
to go to sleep. It will also work wonders
in renewing your daytime energy if you can
find a few moments for it at midday.
But there are other ways to renew your energy
on the job.
She's trying too hard and getting nowhere
fast. Oh my, she spoiled another sheet. In
a case like this pause from your work for
a moment, relax that tension.
In the case of the worker who uses her brawn,
a change to less vigorous refresher activity
will do the trick.
In other words, slow down instead of letting
down all at once. Learn how to save your energy
by conserving your movements.
Restore your energy through sleep. Renew it
through relaxation. Save it by conserving
your movements.
One of the best ways, though, to prevent fatigue
is to build strength within your own body
and to master the knack of doing things, called
body mechanics.
And you can only do that through exercise.
When I speak of exercise I don't mean any
kind of exercise, I mean planned exercise.
The kind that really produces results.
It isn't easy. It's often tiresome. It wears
off those bulges and bumps; it put your weight
in the right places; it gives you an active,
supple and shapely body.
Foundation garments have their place. But
the best foundation garment in the world is
right inside your own body--your muscles.
Any foundation garment wears out with use.
But your muscles do just the opposite. They
gain snap and elasticity the more they are
used.
Proper exercise will save you the embarrassment
of being called one of those attractive from
the neck up girls. And I don't mean the intellectual
type.
Consistent, daily, planned exercise can be
all things to all people.
It can put inches on a thin girl and fill
her out.
It can take inches off the fat girl and slim
her down.
It can re-proportion the girl with the un-symmetrical
figure so that her curves fall in the right
places.
Planned exercise can also aid the internal
mechanism of the body by aiding in the prevention
of constipation and menstrual distress.
But it can't accomplish these miracles alone,
which brings me around to nutrition - perhaps
the most important of the factors could keep
you in perfect physical shape.
Your army meals are carefully planned by expert
dietitians and contain all the food elements
necessary for a well-balanced diet.
Take a look at this tray: there's protein
for muscle building in the hamburger, although
you get it from eggs and cheese as well as
meat.
There is starch for energy in the potatoes
and bread. The sugar in the Fig Newton gives
you more energy.
Minerals and water in the vegetables, fruit
and milk nourish blood and bones.
As for those alphabetical vitamins which are
essential for the prevention of disease, they
are generously represented in all Army menus.
Before we take it away, let's take one more
look at the tray. It's both what you eat and
how much that counts. And that brings us to
the burning question of calories.
A body is similar to a machine. It runs on
fuel called calories. A calorie is a familiar
and convenient name for the unit by which
we the measure fuel value of the food we consume.
In everything we do, these calories are used.
Calories which are not used for activity are
stored in the body is fat.
Your weight depends on the balance between
the calories you take in, and the calories
you need for your daily activities.
If you consume more calories than you need,
you gain weight.
If you take in fewer calories than you need,
you lose weight
If there is a perfect balance between calorie
intake and calorie need, your weight remains
constant.
Surprised? Now you see how important it is
to know the calorie count of the foods you
eat.
But you don't have to skimp at meals. Just
cut out those between meal sweets. Next time,
try fruit or fruit juices instead of that
chock malt.
Tsk, tsk. Think of your weight!
[Your Fortune--You have a broad outlook, a
wide base for your activities. Though life
may put a strain on you in the near future,
there's a bright horizon just beyond.]
Don't be misguided. Your age should not influence
your weight very much but the size of your
frame does.
Here is the correct calculation.
Pardon this note of gloom, but stout people
are more likely to develop chronic diseases
than thin people.
This is due to the extra burden on their vital
organs.
Not being able to make the grade is an extreme
example of what happens to people who avoid
proper rest, daily exercise, wholesome diet.
But there's another more usual result of ignoring
the ABCs of a sensible health regime.
It's a condition common among GIs. It often
appears very funny to the other fellow, but
never to its victim.
"This thing has certainly got her worried."
"No results in three days; that's serious
isn't it?"
"Well not according to what the medical officer
told me. It doesn't have to be a once a day
habit but it does have to be a habit.
She goes at all hours of the day and night
but never two days in succession at the same
time."
"She swallowed half of that bottle in less
than a week."
"How you doing?"
"Hey what's the big idea?"
"Here try this. It will do you more good."
"Since when do you consider yourself a health
authority?"
"Since I stopped concentrating on patent medicines
and started concentrating on coming here at
regular time each day and when I have more
than a couple of seconds.
I'm just passing on what the medical officer
told me. Cut out all the junk you eat and
go in for fresh vegetables and fruits and
drink lots of water."
"Come on now. Since you tried everything else
you might just as well try the easy way."
"Hey come on, get going. You've got exactly
5 minutes before drill."
"I can't drill today I'm unwell."
"Come on get up and take a shower you'll be
all right."
"A shower? Are you insane? It's almost suicide
at this time of the month."
A 20th-century girl still clinging to that
lavender and old lace hokum about no activity,
no bathing during menstruation. That's Victorian
stuff.
And so is the hush-hush about nerves and sensibilities
during this period.
Women are where they are today, and you are
where you are today, because women have learned
to take it in their stride.
And there are other silly superstitions concerning
this perfectly normal function of the female
body. They are as out of place in modern life
as the spinning wheel of the [coting for].
But when I tell some women that menstruation
is no excuse for absenteeism and self coddling,
they look quite hurt and bewildered, and start
bombarding me with all sorts of questions.
"What if you have the cramps and have to go
to bed?"
"Isn't something wrong if if your period doesn't
come every 28 days?"
"Is it abnormal if the amount of flow is always
changing?"
"Are we expected to suffer and still go about
our business as usual when we have the curse?"
"What are the best hygienic protections?"
"How do you know when you're starting your
menopause?"
"Do the nerves always go to pieces during
the menopause?"
Let's clear the fog once and for all by letting
one of your own medical officers answer these
questions, but one at a time.
First I want to say that there is no need
to consider menstruation a curse. It's just
nature's way of ridding your body of its preparation
for pregnancy.
This whole process should take place as painlessly
and as easily as digestion.
The fact that it doesn't with some of you
may be due to a variety of reasons. And that
brings me to that question about cramps.
If you'll notice the position of the uterus
between the rectum and the bladder you will
realize that pressure on it from constipation
will cause cramps and a heavy feeling in the
abdomen.
So will slack abdominal muscles. Good ways
to relieve this feeling are physical activity
and application of heat. They both stimulate
circulation of blood and relax the muscles.
There is as much difference within your body
when your posture is good or poor, as there
is between these two piles of blocks.
When you stand and sit incorrectly your abdominal
organs are so crowded that they have no room
to function efficiently.
But when you stand and sit correctly they
assume their proper place and don't interfere
with your natural functions.
if your posture is good and your abdominal
muscles firm, you'll suffer less pain during
menstruation.
Now as to your question, "Is there something
wrong if your menstrual periods don't come
every 28 days?"
The normal menstrual period can easily vary
between 22 and 40 days, although the usual
time is 28 days.
The duration of the flow usually lasts from
four to five days, but there is no need for
alarm if it lasts only two days or as long
as eight days.
These variations depend on the individual.
The amount of flow also varies with the individual.
With some women it's only scant staining of
a few pads for the entire period.
For others it's saturation from six to eight
pads a day, but profuse flow most generally
takes place the first and second days.
A radical change of climate can bring about
irregularity in the menses. Women who move
from tropical to winter climates find that
they may start skipping periods until they
adjust themselves to the new environment.
And again, changes in habits will also cause
a great change in the amount of flow.
This girl would stop worrying if she knew
that her flow had increased some because she
changed from a sedentary to a physically active
job.
So you see there are many causes for irregularities
in the menses beside the obvious ones of pregnancy
and menopause.
If your periods are irregular, it's a good
thing to go to the medical officer.
The choice between the external pad and the
tampon is a purely personal one, and depends
largely on what you find is a safer and more
convenient protection for you.
The tampon fits into the vagina in this fashion,
but a tampon will be uncomfortable and irritating
if the vagina is small or the menstrual flow
heavy.
In these cases the external pad is far more
satisfactory.
Since the chance of body odors is greater
at this time if you use sanitary pads, change
them often, and take frequent baths and use
deodorants.
And it isn't necessary to douche after your
period or at any other time unless you've
been advised to do so by your doctor.
Artificial cleansing tends to destroy the
body fluids that take care of this cleansing
process naturally.
"How do you know when you're starting your
menopause?"
The symptoms are much the same as those of
adolescence: nervousness, menstrual irregularity,
circulatory disturbances and unbalanced glands.
But adolescence seems a wonderful period as
we look back, doesn't it?
So there is no reason why life still can't
begin at 40. And it often does.
I think many women would lose their fear of
menopause if once they realize that menopause
means only the end of their childbearing life,
and not the end of their sexual life, their
attractiveness or their usefulness.
"Forward march!"
So you see there's no reason to get excited
about normal female functions. They are just
a part of your life. You can always take them
in your stride.
There is one more thought I want to leave
with you on this subject.
Remarkable progress has been made in new therapeutic
treatments for the physical and psychological
disorders that occasionally accompany menopause.
Today no woman need ever again fear this period
in her life.
There is one common ailment which you shouldn't
take in your stride. If you do, your coworkers
have every right to consider you public enemy
number one.
[sneeze] This lady is spreading millions of
cold germs and exposing all these young trainees
and the instructor to possible cold infection.
[cough cough] "You'd better go on sick call.
Now don't give me that routine about 'not
sick enough,' or 'no time.' Do you want to
put all of us in the hospital with pneumonia?
"
Perhaps many of you consider these things
too obvious for discussion, but there are
still women in both army and civilian circles
who don't know what symptoms of physical distress
to take seriously, or vice versa.
There are also those who moan and groan about
vague aches and pains that they can't localize.
One of the causes of their mysterious suffering
that seems to evade their diagnosis, but at
the same time to invade every fiber of their
bodies, is unhappy feet.
Unhappy feet can make a pessimist out of an
optimist overnight.
If you don't like to suffer, see that your
shoes are properly fitted. Trust the judgment
of the fitter as to size. She knows much more
about your feet in the Army than you do.
And that applies both to your dress shoes
and your little Abner's. Be sure to wear wool
socks with these little Abner's.
Don't wear the same pair of shoes each day.
Change off until they're broken in and feel
comfortable. A change eases your feet even
after your shoes are broken in.
That means foot trouble!
And so does this.
First sterilize a needle with a lighted match.
Then prick the blister at the lower end.
Just open enough to empty fluid from the blister.
Don't remove the skin.
Then cover the blister with a good sized strip
of zinc oxide plaster and leave it on for
several days.
For corns or soft corns, report to your medical
officer immediately, and be sure to report
also if you think you have that painful fungus
infection: athlete's foot.
Symptoms are cracked skin, painful inflammation
between or below the toes.
Athlete's foot can spread to others as quickly
as the seven years inch.
The germ thrives on warmth and moisture, swimming
pools and latrines.
The first essential of good foot hygiene is
to keep your feet thoroughly dry.
Always dry your feet well and powder between
your toes before putting on stockings.
And here's another--notice that she's cutting
her nails straight across - not on a curve
- to prevent ingrown toenails.
Yes, it's most important that you treat your
feet with special consideration and respect,
because now that you are in active service,
you are using them much more than you ever
did before.
In fact, many of you have to learn how to
walk all over again. Most civilians don't
know how, because they do so little walking.
Usually they are carried to their destination.
And when they are not going anywhere in particular,
they stroll or dawdle.
But in the Army, I hear tell, you have to
depend on your own feet to take you there.
That's why learning to walk properly is so
important.
Carry your weight toward the outside border
of the feet. Yes your feet make for good posture.
Your feet are the base from which you build
your posture.
Pushing off with your toes and walking from
your hips will give you that 30 inch step
without any strain.
For if your knees snap back your hips are
going to protrude. Keep your knees straight,
but relax
That's right - toes straight ahead, head up--it's
bound to be if you keep your chest high.
It may be an optical illusion, but your ankles
do look slimmer when you walk the right way.
From ankles to smile in one easy jump.
You can't help noticing teeth when they're
framed in such a smile. That's one very, very
good reason for keeping them sparkling clean.
But there are others: Last year the Army Dental
Corps drilled and filled 1,800,000 cavities.
So you see, tooth trouble is also a common
ailment among GIs.
"What causes tooth decay?"
"Oh, a number of things such as poor diet,
not enough vitamins and minerals, too many
sweets.
If you eat before going to bed and forget
to brush your teeth afterwards, particles
of food lodge in the crevices and start to
ferment.
This encourages bacteria. And bacteria increase
the tendency to tooth decay.
That's why it's so important to brush your
teeth regularly and even more important to
brush them correctly,
from the gums downward, or upward."
"Uh, uh--not from side to side but up and
down. Yes, that's right - brush from the gum
downward or upward."
It does them good just to look at her. Yes,
men are simple creatures--it gives them a
lift to see a girl looking her most attractive
on the job.
Vital and freshly wholesome, with that natural
glow that doesn't come in bottles and jars.
Shining teeth, beautiful skin,
for which there's nothing like a good scrubbing.
Although to most of you, it may seem too obvious
to mention, daily bathing is the first must
in the rulebook for feminine attractiveness.
The soap you use should be bland, particularly
if your skin has a tendency to be dry.
Deodorants and perfumes don't kill perspiration
or other body odors. They only make them more
offensive.
Since many women are allergic to depilatorys,
shaving is still the most effective way to
remove superfluous hair.
If you use a facial cream or oil at night,
be sure to remove the excess grease before
going to bed.
For that rosy bloom, a dash of cold water
is the best astringent.
And for chapped lips, use lip pommade or cream.
Scalp lifting is in order to stimulate sluggish
circulation, but for oily hair, do it in combination
with an astringent.
If you'll pardon the suggestion, a good brushing
might be in order.
Gently, gently--I didn't say scalping.
And if you're looking for a change of hairstyling
to suit your facial confirmation and G. I.
regulations, there is the pageboy,
the roll,
the bun,
the up sweep,
the straight shingle,
the curly shingle.
If you wear your hair short, it should be
cut and shaped often. Snip away the hangovers
from the last permanent.
I'm no expert on the problem of makeup.
Since the proper use of cosmetics is an art
in itself, we'll shift the scene to Hollywood
and have an authority on beautifying feminine
faces show you how to make the most of your
face.
"Never use makeup as a mask. Use it to bring
out, not to hide the natural freshness of
your skin, and use it conservatively.
Makeup goes on smoother, looks more natural,
with a foundation cream or liquid.
It provides a lasting makeup and protects
the skin against wind and sun.
The wrong use of rouge can make a woman look
hard or clownish.
Cream rouge is applied directly over the foundation.
Dry rouge is used only after powdering.
To be effective, rouge and powder should not
be detectable. Never use too much rouge; you
can always add more, but you can't cover it.
Application of rouge depends on correct placement.
Cream rouge should be applied with the fingers
and blended until no line of demarcation is
noticeable.
Never use an elongated field of rouge on the
oblong face. Always use a circle.
Never use a circle on the round or square
face. Use an elongated field to create the
illusion of length.
When in doubt for placement of rouge, smile
and place it on the highest point of the cheek.
One should always choose a powder that gives
warmth and brightness to the skin.
In powdering, start at a receding point such
as under the eyes, outer cheeks or receding
chin.
Never powder a large nose first. It will become
a highlight.
Don't try to improve on nature with one of
those thick Ubangi mouths.
Follow the natural line of the lips and don't
use exotic lip shades; they are not chic,
and they are certainly not G.I.
Bite gently on a piece of tissue to set the
lips and remove excess lipstick.
Lipstick smears on handkerchiefs and lipstick
rings on cups are not appealing.
Don't tamper with the natural line of your
eyebrow.
Your eyebrows as nature made them give expression
and character to your face and are functional.
They protect your eyes from strong light and
dust.
These are actually the only articles necessary
for good nail grooming, especially when you're
in the Army.
Fu Manchu talons are out when you wear a uniform
and so is exotic nail polish. If you use polish
see that it is conservative."
She's learned a lot. See how smoothly and
skillfully her makeup is blended. She can
be proud of that job.
And she certainly is proud of her uniform.
And she keeps it in a condition to reflect
that pride.
The hang of your uniform depends not only
on the fitting, but on what you have to hang
it on.
She's very careful about using dress shields
to avoid perspiration, stains and odors.
And being fastidious, she never wears her
undies more than once without laundering them
again.
She even sees to it that her dog tags are
warm and well-dressed.
Yes, by keeping yourselves and your belongings
in perfect shape you are showing the world
and G.I. Joe that you are a mighty sharp looking
lot.
But more important you are also showing them
that efficiency, endurance, stability and
courage are by no means exclusively stag affairs.
[The end. T.F. 8 2093]
[This film will not be shown to the general
public without permission of the War Department]